con críticas predecibles los
republicanos han tratado de vender la
narrativa de que yo baile es culpable de
todo lo que está pasando en afganistán a
pesar de que ni trump ni obama en su
momento retiraron las tropas aún cuando
lo prometieron en campaña y el líder de
la minoría republicana en el senado dijo
que la retirada de las tropas de
afganistán era un condenado de fracaso
al liderazgo estadounidense dijo que el
avance de los talibanes
era de esperarse después de que eeuu
abandonará las fuerzas afganas agregó
también que todo el mundo vio venir esto
- el presidente y bailén y que ahora la
probabilidad de que al qaeda vuelva a
planear ataques desde afganistán está
creciendo por su parte rick scott el
senador republicano por la florida y
potencial candidato a la presidencia y
si no aplicar la enmienda número 25
contra el presidente by den basada en la
incapacidad del presidente de ejercer
sus funciones precisamente tras la
decisión de retirar las tropas de
afganistán enmienda 25 que nunca ha sido
aplicada en la historia de eeuu
daría la potestad al vicepresidente del
gabinete de declarar el presidente no
apto críticas que muchos califican como
oportunistas por parte de los
republicanos que contradicen sus
posiciones y hasta hace poco asumían un
golpe en todo caso para bailén y para
eeuu en una región donde china gana cada
vez más influencia